l'indispensable devoir de mémoire pour
que survivent dans les esprits une fois
les témoins disparus le martyre des
habitants d'oradour sur glane victimes
de la folie meurtrière nazis jacques
chirac ce matin a inauguré ce centre en
appelant à la vigilance contre la
barbarie
françois private red herring un chèque
émotion perceptible sur le visage du
président de la république au milieu des
ruines d'oradour-sur-glane durant plus
d'une heure
jacques chirac accompagné de catherine
trautmann ministre de la culture
écoute le récit de jean-marcel darthout
l'un des six rescapés du village martyre
où j'entendais le bruit de la classe
drôle de sensation qu'on ressent je
crois que ça vise à accompagner des
enfants de l'école d'oradour-sur-glane
jacques chirac inaugure le centre de la
mémoire
exposition permanente construite autour
de la deuxième guerre mondiale
l'occasion pour lui de faire un
parallèle avec les massacres du kosovo
et de rappeler que pour la première fois
dans l'histoire grâce au tribunal pénal
international de la haye un chef d'état
en exercice en la personne de slobodan
milosevic vient d'être inculpé pour
crimes contre l'humanité
le 21e siècle tirant toutes les leçons
du passé sera le siècle de l'éthique
je l'espère je le crois présence lourde
de symboles de catherine trautmann en
1953 l'aministie des malgré nous
alsaciens qui avaient participé au
massacre avait suscité l'indignation en
limousin il est évident que notre propre
marque présente l'alsace prouve aussi
que la réconciliation est fait et se
poursuit ce qui est en train de se
construire entre entre strasbourg et et
oradour c'est sans doute une forme de
réconciliation sur le livre d'or
d'oradour-sur-glane ces quelques mots de
jacques chirac
les lieux de mémoire lieu de souffrance
et de violence nous confronte à l'avenir
autant qu'au passé